let's talk dirty a few years ago
oddly enough I needed the bathroom and I
found one a public bathroom and I went
into the stall and I prepared to do what
I'd done most of my life use the toilet
flush the toilet forget about the toilet
and for some reason that day instead I
asked myself a question and it was where
does this stuff go and with that
question
I found myself plunged into the world of
sanitation there's more coming
sanitation toilets and poop and I have
yet to emerge and that's because it's
such an amazing yet engaging place to be
to go back to that toilet wasn't a
particularly fancy toilet wasn't as nice
as this one from the World Toilet
organization that's the other WTO but it
had a lockable door it had privacy I had
water it had so so I could wash my hands
and I did because I'm a woman and we do
that
but that day when I asked that question
I learned something and that was that
I'd grown up thinking that a toilet like
that was my right when in fact it's a
privilege 2.5 billion people worldwide
have no adequate toilet they don't have
a bucket or a box 40% of the world with
no adequate toilet and they have to do
what this little boy is doing by the
side of the Mumbai Airport expressway
which is called open defecation or
pooh-poohing in the open and he does
that every day and every day probably
that guy in the picture walks on by
because he sees that little boy but he
doesn't see him but he should because
the problem with all that poop lying
around is that poop carries passengers
50 communicable diseases like to travel
in human [ __ ] all those things the eggs
the cysts the bacteria the viruses all
those can travel in one gram of human
feces how well that little boy will not
have washed his hand he's barefoot he'll
run back into his house and he will
contaminate his drinking water and his
food and his environment with whatever
diseases he may be carrying by fecal
particles that are on his fingers and
feet in what I call the flushed and
plumbed world that most of us in this
room are lucky to live in the most
common symptoms associated with those
diseases diarrhea is now a bit of a joke
it's the runs the Hershey squirts the
squits
where I come from we call it Delhi Belly
as a legacy of Empire but if you search
for a stock photo of diarrhea in ER in a
leading photo image agency this is the
picture that you come up with
still not sure about the bikini and
here's another image of diarrhea this is
Marie Sayle 9 months old you can't see
her she's buried under that green grass
in a little village in Liberia because
she died in three days from diarrhea the
Hershey squirts the runs a joke and
that's her dad but she wasn't alone that
day because 4,000 other children died of
diarrhea and they do everyday diarrhea
is the second biggest killer of children
worldwide and you've probably been asked
to care about things like hiv/aids or TB
or measles but diarrhea kills more
children than all those three things put
together it's a very potent weapon of
mass destruction and the cost to the
world is immense two hundred sixty
billion dollars lost every year on the
on the losses to poor sanitation
these are cholera beds in Haiti you'll
have heard of cholera but we don't hear
about diarrhea it gets a fraction of the
attention and funding given to any of
those other diseases but we know how to
fix this we know because in the mid
nineteenth century wonderful Victorian
engineers installed systems of sewers
and wastewater treatment in the flush
toilet and disease dropped dramatically
child mortality dropped by the most that
had ever dropped in history the flush
toilet was voted the best medical
advance of the last 200 years by the
readers of the British Medical Journal
and they were choosing over the pill
anesthesia and surgery it's a wonderful
waste disposal device but I think that
it's so good it doesn't smell we can put
it in our house we can lock it behind
the door and I think we've locked it out
of conversation too we don't have a
neutral word for it oops not
particularly adequate [ __ ] offends
people feces is to medical because I
can't explain otherwise when I look at
the figures what's going on we know how
to solve diarrhea in salads
but if you look at the budgets of
countries developing and developed you
think there's something wrong with the
math because you'll expect absurdities
like Pakistan spending 47 times more on
its military than it does on water and
sanitation even though a hundred and
fifty thousand children die of diarrhea
in Pakistan every year but then you look
at that already miniscule water and
sanitation budget and 75 to 90 percent
of it will go on clean water supply
which is great we all need water no
one's going to refuse clean water but
the humble latrine or flush toilet
reduces disease by twice as much as just
putting in clean water think about it
that little boy who's running back into
his house he may have a nice clean fresh
water supply but he's got dirty hands
that he's gonna contaminate his water
supply with and I think that the real
waste of human waste is that we are
wasting it as a resource and as an
incredible trigger for development
because these are a few things that
toilets and poop itself can do for us so
a toilet can put a girl back in school
25% of girls in India drop out of school
because they have no adequate sanitation
they've been used to sitting through
lessons for years and years holding it
in we've all done that but they do it
every day and when they hit puberty and
they start menstruating it just gets too
much and I understand that who can blame
them so if you met an educationalist and
said I can improve education attendance
rates by 25% with just one simple thing
you'd make a lot of friends in education
that's not the only thing it can do for
you poop can cook your dinner it's got
nutrients in it we ingest nutrients we
excrete nutrients as well we don't keep
them all in Rwanda they're now getting
75% of their cooking fuel in their
prison system from the contents of
prisoners bowels so these are a bunch of
inmates in a prison in boot RA they're
genocidal inmates most of them and
they're stirring the content of their
own latrines because if you put poop in
a sealed environment in a
hanck pretty much like a stomach then
pretty much like a stomach it gives off
gas and you can cook with it and you
might think it's just good karma to see
these guys stirring [ __ ] but it's also a
good economic sense because they're
saving a million dollars a year they're
cutting down on deforestation and they
found a fuel supply that is
inexhaustible infinite and free at the
point of production it's not just in the
poor world that poop can save lives
here's a woman who's about to get a dose
of the brown stuff in those syringes
which is what you think it is except not
quite because it's actually donated
there is now a new career path called
stool donor it's like the news perm
donor because she has been suffering
from a super bug called c-diff and it's
resistant to antibiotics in in many
cases she's been suffering for years she
gets a dose of healthy human feces and
the cure rate for this procedure is 94%
it's astonishing but hardly anyone is
still doing it maybe it's the ick factor
that's ok because there's a team of
research scientists in Canada which have
now created a stool sample a fake stool
sample which is called repopulate so
you'll be thinking by now ok the
solutions simple we give everyone a
toilet this is where it gets really
interesting because it's not that simple
because we are not simple so the really
interesting exciting work this is what
the engaging bit is is in sanitation is
that we need to understand human
psychology we need to understand
software as well as just giving someone
hardware they found in many developing
countries that governments have gone in
and given out free latrines and gone
back a few years later and found that
they've got lots of new goat sheds or
temples or spare rooms with their owners
happily walking past them and going over
to the open defecating ground so the
idea is to manipulate human emotion it's
been done for decades the soap companies
did it in the early 20th century they
tried selling soap as healthy no one
bought it they tried telling the selling
into sexy everyone bought it in India
now there's a campaign which persuades
young Brides not
to marry into families that don't have a
toilet it's called no loo no I do and in
case you think that post is just
propaganda here's Priyanka 23 years old
I met her last October in India and she
grew up in a conservative environment
grew up in a rural village in poor area
of India and she was engaged at 14 and
then at 2021 or so she moved into her
in-laws house and she was horrified to
get there and find that they didn't have
a toilet she grown up with a latrine it
was no big deal but it was a latrine and
the first night she was there she was
told that at 4 o'clock in the morning
her mother-in-law got her up told her to
go outside and go and do it in the dark
in the open and she was scared she was
scared of drunks hanging around she was
scared of snakes she was scared of rape
after three days she did another
thinkable thing she left and if you know
anything about rural India you know
that's an unspeakably courageous thing
to do but not just that she got her
toilet and now she goes around all the
other villages and India's persuading
other women to do the same thing it's
what I call social contagion and it's
really powerful and really exciting
another version of this another village
in India what near where Priyanka lives
is this village called la cara and about
a year ago it had no toilets whatsoever
kids were dying of diarrhea and cholera
so visitors came using various
behavioral change tricks like putting
out a plate of food and a plate of [ __ ]
and watching the flies go one to the
other somehow people who'd been thinking
that what they were doing was not
disgusting at all suddenly thought oops
not only that but they were ingesting
their neighbor's [ __ ] that's what really
made them change their behavior so this
woman this this this boy's mother
installed this latrine in a few hours
her entire life she'd been using the
banana field behind that she installed a
litter in a few hours it cost nothing
it's gonna save that boy's life
so when I get despondent about the state
of sanitation even though these are
pretty exciting times because we've got
the Bill and Melinda Gates Foundation
reinventing the toilet which is great
we've got Matt Damon going on bathroom
strike which is great for Humanity very
bad for his colon but there are things
to worry about its most off-track
Millennium
Development Goal it's about 50 or so
years off-track we're not going to meet
targets providing people with sanitation
at this rate so when I get sad about
sanitation I think of Japan because
Japan 70 years ago was a nation of
people who used pit latrines and wiped
with sticks and now it's a nation of
what are called washer otto's wash ilat
toilets they have inbuilt bidet nozzles
for a lovely hand free cleaning
experience and they have various other
features like a heated seat and the
automatic lid raising device which is
known as the marriage saver but most
importantly what they have done in Japan
which I find so inspiration is they
brought the toilet out from behind the
locked door they've made it
conversational people go out and upgrade
their toilet they talk about it
they've sanitized it I hope that we can
do that it's not a difficult thing to do
all we really need to do is look at this
issue as the urgent shameful issue that
it is and don't think that it's just in
the poor world that things are wrong our
sewers are crumbling things are going
wrong here too the solution to all of
this is pretty easy
I'm gonna make your lives easier this
afternoon and just ask you to do one
thing and that's to go out protest speak
about the unspeakable and talk [ __ ]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
you